[Music]  three four space looks like  [Music]  I'm out  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  looks like I'm out  [Music]  [Music]  what is being  I'm out  [Music]  Hey little help  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  to get smoked  take me with you  oh I'm actually the bad guy whatever bad  boy  [Music]  whoa  [Music]  that was amazing dude are you crying no  no you're you like this year this video  and the other graders who put out the  bin that's when the best videos have  never made on youtube so if you're not  subscribed to our Channel consider doing  so and Freddie thank you for  collaborating with us man it's been like  eight years and we haven't officially  collaborated until now and look the  magical name let's do it again  thanks for watching